سوق اشتهر بالكامل ببوش بازار في مدينه
كابول وذلك لان البضائع في هذا السوق كان
يتم توريدها من القواعد العسكريه الاجنبيه
وخاصه الامريكيه وكان المترجمون الفوريون
وسائقون والطاهات في المعسكرات الامريكيه
قد جلبوا هذه البضائع وباعوها في هددا
السوق قبل اكثر من 15 عاما وكان قبل ذلك
يسمى بسوق اريا فاشتهر بابوش بازار يتم في
هذا السوق بيع الملابس المستعمله والمعدات
الامريكيه
والمكملات الغذائيه والادوات الكهربائيه
والاجهزه الالكترونيه والمنزليه والعناصر
الاخرى التي يحتاجها الجيش من ماكولات
ومشروبات وتعتبر بشكل عام من ذات نوعيه
جيده
الاشياء التي يتم بيعها في هذه السوق
عاليه الجوده وذلك انها اجنبيه
والزبائن يفضلونها على غيرها يقول
البائعون في هذا السوق ان معظم سبائنهم ما
زالوا يطلبون منهم ادوات واجهزه امريكيه
لكن بما ان هذه المصادر قد توقفت فان
اعمالهم التجاريه تواجه ركودا منذ شهور
طبيعي في التحولات السياسيه وبالتالي
تواجه تجارتنا تقلصا كبيرا في هذه الايام
كما ان عدد الزبائن قليل كان هذا السوق
يحمل اسم سوق الاريا قبل وصول القوات
الامريكيه الى البلاد وبعد السيطره طالبان
على كابول لم يعد الاسم السابق الى المسمى
فغير الطالبان اسمه بوشباز الى مجاهدين
بازار في وقت ما زال السوق يشتهر بين
المواطنين ببوش باز بازار بوش الابن يشبه
بازار برج زعيم الاتحاد السوفيتيه السابقه
والذي تم انشائه ايام التواجد القوات
السوفياتيه في افغانستان ثم اختفى ذاك
السوق بعد انسحاب تلك القوات من البلد
يبدو ان هذا السوق سيواجه المصير نفسه
عبدو نادر العربيه كابول